morgan wallin is a finalist in six
categories at the 2021 billboard music
awards because of his massive sales and
streams over the past year
but since he was recorded saying the
n-word earlier this year
producers have said he is banned from
the may 23rd
award show yeah dick clark productions
says
unique among award shows billboard music
awards finalists are determined by
performance
on the billboard charts and are not
chosen by a voting committee or
membership organization
morgan wallin is the finalist this year
based on charting as his recent conduct
does not align with our core values we
will not be including him on the show in
any capacity
performing presenting accepting it is
heartening and encouraging to hear that
morgan is taking steps
in his anti-racist journey and starting
to do some meaningful work
we plan to evaluate his progress and
will consider his participation in
future shows
just a couple of weeks ago morgan posted
a handwritten letter on instagram saying
in part
to release this project and watch y'all
make a country album go
ten consecutive weeks at number one all
genre is literally unheard of
that's never happened before from what
i'm told i didn't even know that
this record existed to be honest it
wasn't what i set out to accomplish but
your response has meant
so so much to me i just want you to know
how much this means to me and it always
will
i wanted to let you guys know that i've
taken a couple of months away and i feel
like i've
really worked on myself i'm proud of the
work i've put in and
and in many ways thankful to have had
time to do it
yes he continued i found this time away
to be very valuable to me in many ways
but i feel like i need more of it
and therefore will not be performing
tour dates this summer it means i won't
be playing festivals or the luke ryan
tour dates
but it's important to me personally if
you can still go to these shows
support country music right says i
understand the nominations but i think
but i think they made the right call
here by banning him and he says the n
word needs not to be said but yeah i
think
what do you think about because the
weird thing is like he's going to win
he's probably going to win his
categories because he had
it's all based on sales right so he's
going to win these categories so they're
probably not going to broadcast those
categories but yeah what do you think of
him being still
included in the finalists thank you
yeah you know i talked to him right when
he did the snl event uh you know when he
was brought back because
you know first time they didn't want him
back they wanted him back to talk about
his experience and
him partying during cobit and all of
that um
yeah i'm glad that they're sticking to
their core values and that they
you know he's recognized that he's made
a mistake and
his music still speaks people loved his
album and that needs to be celebrated
because
it's on the charts however i'm glad that
he wrote this note saying that he's
working on himself and that he's
taken a moment away and he's
acknowledging it the fact that he put
out an apology is important as well but
i'm glad that he's not gonna be part of
the show
yeah i like the way billboard handled it
i mean obviously
he had success and that's what billboard
is about is highlighting success
and they're not gonna break the rules
just because of the situation i
appreciate that they nominated him
i also appreciate that their statement i
really like that they even said at the
end you know we're gonna monitor his
progress
if he's gonna continue to go on this
anti-racist journey we'll monitor and
maybe we can invite him
i mean because i feel i feel like things
are encouraging you know i have a real
struggle with cancel culture because the
question has always been for me
is this a teachable moment can someone
learn can someone change
can somebody be so affected by this that
they learn it i obviously you know you
don't i don't want to defend anybody
that's racist i have no tolerance for
racism but
i really do believe in humanity and
people's ability to change or just want
to try and be better
we don't know people's circumstances so
i just want to be
just mindful of that at the end of the
day his core group
wasn't going to cancel him i said that
from the very beginning
um especially because that apology that
he read on his laptop was very
half-assed
someone answered the phone now
somebody's calling it police it's the
feds
somebody call it whose phone is that
who's calling thank you
i have a phone i actually have a phone
in the house you have a house phone
i have a house phone oh they're still
calling
i think morgan's calling it's fine but
you know
at the end of the day at the end of the
day you know the n-word doesn't just
slip out if it's not already
something you say naturally if it's not
already in your vocabulary he did
promise to do better
after the snl incident he didn't do
better
but now he's taking time away he already
made a big bag of money by the success
of these songs so he can afford to take
the summer off
but regardless yeah i hope that he
learned something from this
and i hope that he can be a better
influence on this world because he is
talented
yeah paulus is that's wrong he made a
mistake but it has not since show
compassion
dances everyone has the opportunity to
change um
q says that's good that they banned him
from the awards but he made racist
comments that never should have
uh said in the first place so his career
is over his career is definitely over
because
his sales have been crazy uh even since
the incident and she says i'm glad he's
doing the work hopefully he'll come back
wiser can change
have a change of heart uh along the way
that's just the banning is okay
those are consequences it's not
cancellations consequences yeah nelson
says it's good everyone can see the
consequences
yeah it's a weird situation because it's
not like like billboard said it's not
done by committee
like that determines his nomination like
they don't even call them nominees they
call them finalists
because even with like now with the
award show it's not like they're all
going to vote no it's lily who sold the
most that who that's who wins the award
so
he's clearly going to win some
categories i know billboard has so many
categories
that they don't present them all in the
show anyways like kind of the end
credits they say
who else won awards so i'm sure that's
what they're going to do with morgan
wallin's categories that he won't be
announced
a winner in any of them so yeah it's a
weird situation like yeah
it might be odd to ban him from this
year's awards in terms of even being a
finalist when
he obviously had huge sales so at least
they're acknowledging it and
yeah we'll see you know how he emerges
from this in the end but yeah it's a
weird situation but i'm
once again i'm glad morgan wallin has
suffered major consequences like he got
banned from radio country radio right
away
like people dropped him like within 24
hours it all fell apart from morgan
wallin which was a huge thing
because he really was at that point the
biggest uh country music star like he
was number one on
the billboard charts so for everyone for
the country community to say like no
like because yeah he was banned from the
cmas and acm so
it's great that the country music
community really stood up and said no
like we're not about this
so yeah it's a great step forward so
we'll see how he emerges in the future
yeah in a couple months and i think you
make a really good point there
it's about it's about the charting sorry
it's about the fans right like these
charting numbers you
those are not you know people are not
voting and so it he will win awards
he had a massive album and uh and it
still
is still getting massive numbers to this
day so
yeah it's an interesting situation all i
know is you do not want to pull up to an
award show with rappers
if they know you said the n-word you
better keep your mask on
keep your head down get security because
it ain't going too fast
yeah and i think there's an award a
change maker award this year as well
right and i think
who's going to be getting it someone's
got a killer killer mike
uh is getting the change maker award too
so there's you know there is some
acknowledgement some changes that are
happening towards the award show and
acknowledging it so
uh i'm looking forward to it though i i
think it's gonna be a good one this year